Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr
and it's the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
Yay.
Sorry man.
I'm running out of ways to say it.
I try to do it differently every week
cause I know people are starting to do
mashups up and so I
tried to give you some,
I'm trying to give you something to work
with. Um, I'm doing this on a Friday.
Why you ask?
It's like what the fuck bill?
The Monday morning podcast is always late.
Did you come up with
the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday?
Just just to,
just to disappoint us twice in one week.
Huh?
Like the podcasting version
of a dead beat. Father
dead be dead. Why is it a dead
beat father? I'll tell you why.
Because there's no alliteration and on
the news you can't keep people sitting
there listening with their mouths, hanging
out her up next dead beat fathers. Nah,
that doesn't work up.
Next dead beat dads wanted a doing
d dead beat dads dead beat dads at
[inaudible] up next on Ktl a Sarah,
can you tell us your story about
being married to a deadbeat dad?
Well,
you know,
I probably shouldn't have stuck his dick
on the first date and he said I'm going
to come. And for some reason I
don't know what I was thinking,
but I just crammed it into my clam
hole and that. So we had our first kid.
Well, I mean, nine
months later, I'm sorry,
I'm nervous because I'm on TV and right
off the bat it's like he take us to
Denny's and the check would come
and he would be like, excuse me,
I have to go to the bathroom.
And I never saw him again.
We tracked him down.
Dead beat dad.
Danny come out of this dilapidated fucking
something that begins with the day.
Um, we just want to give you your
chance to tell your side of the story.
I love those fucking things.
Those,
those new stories where they expose
bad people, like they give a fuck.
You know what I mean?
They don't give a fuck.
They just know that we like sitting
back watching people get in trouble.
Is there anything better than that than
watching somebody getting yelled at?
It's fucking phenomenal.
It's like you can see last week when
I went off on the Burger King Guy,
I didn't even know his name.
I didn't even know how many
fucking rounds there were.
And I clearly stated that I was making
fun of someone that could beat the shit
out of me. Right. So what do
you constitute? You chop it up.
You leave out this where the part where
I say I'm just some more on in a fucking
in my office. It shopped the whole fucking
thing up and then you start put, oh,
a fucking comedian goes on rent.
What are you doing nia?
I'm giving these guys shit for,
they fucked me over last week.
I you're talking about a
safe corner [inaudible] hour.
Yeah. Neil loves him. A great guy.
But I did tweet that.
I was giving that, uh,
that when a little bit of the side,
I know he'd be,
they stopped it because obviously that
guy was gassed or something would've got
hurt. Think so. Like it's just, I feel
like he was this, can't do this again.
We can't do this again. Not to
down, but not out obviously.
I don't know all the rules,
but he knocked him down shore
and then he covered his head.
We don't protect this head.
One of the thoughts
or anything. We were just excited
for the underdog. We were showing,
I met grant and we were like, how bad
ass is? That guy's chest tattoo though.
You got to being about his bad ass.
You've got to be in the sickest shape
ever to pull off the fucking that guy.
He's basically signed himself up to
fucking pull up like pushups and spin
classes for the rest of his fucking
life. Spin classes now. But you know,
some of it because he's been
on TV kicking people's asses.
Then he can just be like, well I did that
and that's why I had so much shit. Like,
that's the thing that's so hilarious
about him and the shaver gets him in
trouble. Do me a favor, tell me,
tell them the tea story and then I got
to blow through the rest of this and then
I got a, I got to drop my
truck off to get the story.
So I'll,
I'll say Aka bills add or
just not paying attention.
Maybe. No, that's not true. Knees
laying in bed. She's like, oh,
can you go get me some tea?
Cause when you get married you're also
like a waiter and bill's like, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh.
Do you want,
I say I like I a cup of
green tea would be lovely.
Just not the caffeinated coffee. He
said, not the caffeinated, caffeinated,
regular, you know, what did
I say? And you went, Oh hey,
I knocked the cafeteria and then you
walked out the door and I just sat there
thinking he's not going to get this right.
He's not.
And sure enough, he came downstairs with
your big sweet smile. Hey goes sweetie.
And sure enough,
it's the decaffeinated.
See when I told you we cannot,
not the cafe.
I thought there was the
caffeinated and not to caffeinated.
So when you said not the captain and
I was like, Oh, good to caffeinated.
I thought it was like fiction and
nonfiction. I don't drink tea or coffee.
So I was like, all right, that's
not to caffeinated, caffeinated.
What you should have
said. Oh No, I should,
I wasn't thinking you should have
said no, I was not, not the captain.
And we have to use a double negative to
get your brain to work correctly. Well,
you'd say, well I want a book, not
nonfiction. No, you wouldn't say that.
You would say I want a fiction book. I
just, but yeah, but you can also say,
I want a book, not nonfiction also.
That means fiction new for you.
If I just said green tea,
you would just listen.
You would have screwed it up regardless.
It's like get any points for trying.
I you do. And you were very sweet
to even gave me a cup of tea. Oh,
don't talk to me like I'm fucking
neck against some mental issue. Well,
you were very sweet. Is that what I am?
I'm that person.
The person who is never going to get laid
and just stays in his hometown for the
rest of his life.
He's sweet.
Can you help me carry this
thing that's really heavy?
I don't think that's what's happened,
but you are me. You are pretty, uh,
I'm pretty, what's the word?
Slow on the uptake. Alright,
listen, I gotta knock this out cause I
gotta drop my truck off today. All right,
you've got to follow me. Okay.
All right. That's it for me.
Well, I gotta I gotta go.
Yeah,
I got to trash them. I was pretty good.
I got to trash him for, uh, you know,
I was making fun of the guy there
and the tidy whities that's what I,
one thing I did like about Conor McGregor
is that when he was going on that Greg
our,
when he came out and the tighty whities
what saying what I did like about that
is you got an idea of what it would be
like if you broke into his home in the
middle of the night.
He come out with that crazy luck that
he did between round one and two, like,
hey,
you want to
come out in his bare feet
a fucking put his heel, he,
you'd sit, he do this spinning
thing. The best sound,
even though you're
getting your ass kicked,
would be him running across the
hardwood floor, the slap of his feet.
And then he do this spinning thing.
Just like,
then he started with a spinning kick
or was that somebody, I think he did.
And that would be right at him or
was that the, it all ran together.
I forgot to say the fight
before the fight of the night.
Bloody like nightmare over there.
Yeah,
that was a two were the sickest warriors.
I've deaf guy.
Finally his fucking nose just exploded.
It was unreal. She near wanted all race.
I was like, no, I have to,
what? I've got to Wa I live,
I'm such a fucking tub of shit that I
have to watch guys fighting at that level
just to get myself to
take my dog on a hike.
And you know what,
we fast forwarded through it but I uh,
I think I read that Sinead O'connor like
came out and sang with Conor McGregor.
I'm only going to say it
like that from now on,
so I have to go back and
watch that. I mean I don't, I,
I think I read that on the Internet
but I may be wrong. I have to go back
and chill.
It's funny you brought her up and I know
she doesn't think this thing sing this
song,
but I thought it was that the who married
the old creepy guy that's saying on
the boat,
let's say, let's say another episode
of what is bill talking about?
Woo.
Whitney Whitney Houston. Oh sorry.
First done by Dolly Parton. All wait,
can you tell,
can you tell everybody
when you were just trying
to describe a gone girl,
what did you call where the [inaudible]
but the thing is,
I know I'm wrong,
but I do it like I do it
like the $10,000 pyramid.
I just start throwing clues
where the bitch really though,
that's a really brilliant,
because Hollywood keeps
remaking movies now.
Cause everybody stole
the movies so they can't,
they can't do anything originally.
Marcus, what's the point?
They just got to keep
doing shit that works.
So they'll do the black version of it
will, which will be where the bitch go.
And then Paul, Paul, Paul C we'll
do, we'll do the all female one.
An alternative to a fucking 10 zillion
dollar a comedy. Where'd the dude bro Go?
I don't know where it would be. I don't
know what it'd be. All right, let me,
let me finish this so I can get
outta here. So as I mentioned today,
very exciting day for me is uh,
my,
the power steering in the
air conditioning units.
Would it be him motors came
in from my truck. So a,
for those of you is not
mechanically inclined as myself.
I've since learned the amount,
those on the front of the engine,
you know that belt that goes all around,
it's just using the front end of the
crank shaft and that's what turns the
fucking motor. Then that's what
gets it going. I don't fucking know.
That's how it works. Um, at least
that's how it gets the motor going.
That's a very simplistic version of it.
So now my truck will have power steering,
which, you know, I was one of those
guys, I'm going to keep it all original.
I'm going to keep it all
original, but like, you know,
it had drum brakes and just
driving out here, drum brakes,
no power steering original suspension.
It's every time I went over a bump I
had to hold onto the seat so my head
wouldn't hit the fucking ceiling.
Um,
the roof of the cab there if it
was a significant one. And um,
you know,
if there's somebody behind me and I'm
trying to parallel park and I'm holding
them up, you know, that panic,
I got to get in the spot,
I would literally be out of
breath. And, um, so anyways,
so I'm, I'm just updating it, keeping,
I still kept it three on the tree.
I got the whole engine redone,
it's running, it's running so well.
I'm not scared about saying how
fucking great it's running. Um,
so today I'm getting the, uh, the power
steering in the air conditioning done.
And then also I went on Ebay and,
uh,
I have an aftermarket horn on my
truck and it's just the high note.
So it's like, hey, it's
such a bad ass truck.
And an I beeped the horn and it just
sounds like the worst fucking thing ever.
So I found somebody, uh, I don't
know how the fuck they got it,
took it off a truck. I had it in
a junk yard, but they had the low,
the low whatever, the low note
and the high note. And, um, uh,
they're going to slap that
on. So it actually sounds
like a fucking man's truck.
And then I think at that point I'm done.
Oh,
I still need the directionals
and the reverse lights to work.
And that's the reason why my wife put
the Kibosh on me getting a 65 galaxy.
So I gotta I gotta hold off on that. She
actually made a great argument. She goes,
we already have one old car that
constantly needs work. And I'm like, no,
I'm getting to this to the point
where it's going to be totally fixed.
And she just like, you know, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. So whatever,
I haven't given up on the fight,
but sometimes you just got to realize when
it'd be like, you know what, you know,
stick and move. I kind of put
it out there, I'll wear it down.
I wear it down the same way she does
when she wants a pair of fucking shoes or
something. But I really like, um,
so anyways, the continuing story, uh,
of me not booze and trying to lose fucking
weight, I weighed myself this morning.
Um, and I'll tell you I had
a rough week, you know, um,
I did not Boosie and this
week started off, uh,
started off a little, hit her
reform. Um, I was, I started, I quit.
And on July 5th going on
a 72 day liver cleanse,
which by the way, I don't even know that
that's how many days you need, you know.
Um, I basically talked
to Dr. Paul [inaudible].
Paul [inaudible] was the one that says,
you know, dude, I argue, you know,
I heard you needed like fucking 72 days.
So I just took that as law. I was like,
well, that's my buddy Paul Versey. He
never went to medical school. I'm sure he,
he overheard it. And a bar
from a us, somebody with a
doctorate and something. Um,
so I am going to go the 72
days considering I fucking
booze like a maniac from
that southern tour, the end of April,
right on through, right on through to a,
the July 5th.
So to get everybody caught up.
So I'm trying to lose three pounds a week.
When I started this,
I was one 86.68 and belly fat face.
Did I know the news, fat
freckles exposed. Um,
so last week I weighed myself.
I was one 83.2 and I'm halfway
through this week. Now.
This week started off rough. Who?
Boy? Or of one? Um, on Monday night,
Monday night, I, uh,
I took my lovely wife to go see steely
Dan with Elvis Costello opening up and I
got to tell you,
that was easily,
that might've been the best
concert I ever saw. I mean,
Elvis Costello comes out and just fucking,
just destroy, like he had such
it, like I'm sitting there,
I'm sitting in the crowd
when Elvis Costello is going
to fucking open this thing.
This is ridiculous. Um, you know,
sky's been headline and for
40 fucking years. And, uh,
he came out and he had such a sense
of humor about it. He played all the,
some weird Illuminati song that
they were like the chosen ones.
So immediately I'm like, this is going to
be a, this is going to be fucking great.
And he came out,
played some newer shit,
played a bunch of classic hits
and he just kept going and going.
And what's funny about the Hollywood
bowl is down low, you know,
I got great fucking seats right
in, down low. They have, um,
they have like these like picnic tables
kind of things. You can get this.
And what was funny is I'm watching Elvis
Costello and he went on early first.
I mean,
and uh,
it's still light out and there was so
many people eating where like it was like
a groups of four.
So two people who are in the front seats
closer to the stage would be turning
around facing the people
they were talking to, eating.
There was so many people turned around
while Elvis was initially on stage that I
was looking at so many faces.
I almost felt like I was on stage.
It was fucking hilarious.
But then he just went into the hits.
And when he played that, uh,
I don't know his shit that
dayday around. Damn. Damn. Damn.
Damn. Everybody fucking went nuts.
And the sun had gone down.
Oh well darn has set some fucking asshole.
Flew right over the Hollywood
bowl at about four or 500 feet.
Now I am a novice. I just got my
license. But as far as I know,
you can't fucking do that. You can do that
when it's empty. But as far as I know,
and outdoor arena with the
significant gathering of human beings,
one hour before the event to one hour
after is a temporary no fly zone.
But this fucker flew over at twice.
And that was being that
fucking guy with a hobby.
My wife's trying to enjoy the
show and I'm like, he can't,
she's like shut up.
So by the way,
I'm embarrassed to say that
I wasn't aware that um,
Elvis Costello has had basically the
same drummer for 40 years because I was
watching the guy going
after once. I was like, wow,
that guy's really good at two songs
I was saying near as any better than
watching a professional drummer.
They've got fucking fluid and just smooth.
That guy is,
and then I ended up looking him up,
guys name is Pete Thomas
does not get enough credit,
but every drummer out there knows who
the fuck he is and was blown away by him.
All right. And then his, his night ended.
I would've been fine with Elvis Costello
band. I would have been fine with that.
And then,
um,
stealy dad came out and did the greatest
live band I've ever fucking seen.
How intricate and how like amazing
their albums are. They came out,
they sounded exactly like the albums
and they got Keith Carlock on drums who
played drums so fucking well
that it transcended like music.
He was playing drums so well I was
thinking about how can I get better as a
comedian.
Like I want to do standup as well,
if I can do it half as well
as this guy's playing drums.
And my wife took this amazing clip.
Um,
I'd even think I was so fucking
blown away by his, his playing.
I didn't take any video. I just sat
there with my fucking John the ground.
And um, this is what a bad ass
he is. Two songs into the set.
They played Asia and he fucking
destroyed it. Absolutely destroyed it.
Effortless was amazing.
Just fucking amazing.
How fluid isn't it fucking that Mola
movement thing that he does where it looks
like both of his fucking arms are doing
the worm just flying down the toms.
But it wasn't overplaying. It was
all tasteful. The dynamics. He just,
he's a fucking beast.
If you ever get a chance,
cause I remember when I lived in New York,
that guy would do a lot of stuff
down in the village, just sit in.
I would just follow him on Twitter.
Uh,
I'm sure he announces the live
gigs and all that when he's around.
If you ever just want to fucking sit like,
you know,
20 feet away from arguably the greatest
drummer of his fucking generation,
I would say check that guy out.
Um,
and right now obviously he's on
tour and um, it's a long story,
but I got to know him a
little bit through, uh,
the guy who sets up all my radio tours.
So he hooked us up with the tickets and
then afterwards I got to fucking talk to
him for two seconds. I swear to God,
just like a total fucking drummy groupie.
And you know, I avoided asking him all
the drum questions I wanted to ask like,
can you teach me some
of the fills in Asia?
Can you just hammer them
out here on this trashcan?
I just wasn't going to do
that because you know why?
Because I was sober is old
Billy drunk tank didn't,
wasn't drinking and I,
and I was aware enough not to do that.
And all I needed was a couple of
Mila highlights and I would've been,
I would've asked him all
kinds of questions and he
would have been crawling up
the walls trying to get away from me. So
there's another reason not to drink. Um,
so anyways, please go see them
if you get a fucking chance. Um,
I know they just played New Mexico,
whatever, but they were fucking amazing.
So anyways,
um,
what else did I want to talk
about? So, Oh, speaking of flying,
I'm all over the map here today.
People,
I'm actually leaving tomorrow to fly up
to Ottawa to play some Blues Festival
where I'm doing standup
outside in between two bands,
which usually is a hell gig.
But they're telling me that all these
awesome comics have done it and it's,
and it's a great gig. So I'm hoping
it's going to be that. If it isn't,
it's just going to be 45 awful
minutes in my life. That's it.
That's how I always look at him. Like,
all right, this is going to suck,
but in 45 minutes,
it's going to be over and I'm going
to be in the car and I'm going to,
it's not going to matter. And I'm going
to go back to my room and I'm going to,
uh, put a pillow over my face and
I'm going to cry myself to sleep.
I picked this job. Um, and then I do
the Montreal comedy festival. And as,
as mentioned, I'm playing three
nights on the comedy jam. Oh,
Billy woodshed there, uh,
three different songs and um,
and then I'm doing three
shows a at a theater up there.
I forget what the fuck it is, but uh,
I'm really looking forward to it. And um,
you know, not gonna Boosie
that's going to be difficult.
That was really difficult during,
uh,
going to a concert to not
drink or anything or get
any sort of a buzz. But, uh,
I stuck with the waters for a minute and
then I finally got like a Turkey wrap
or whatever.
So long story fucking short.
I weighed myself today and I am the
fuck was it one 81.41 81.6 I basically
dropped five pounds.
That's how much I boost.
Just stopping boozing.
I dropped five.
How hard is it to the
lose five fucking pounds?
It's really fucking hard for me anyways.
And I dropped five pounds, so I'm,
so I'm on the, I'm on the
fucking road here. All right.
I gotta I gotta buy next Monday.
I gotta be one 80 and then I'm
keeping it going three pounds a week.
Everybody three pounds a week for
two months. Do it with me. All right.
Have you fucking oatmeal every morning
with a banana and then have an apple or
an orange is a snack.
Somebody told me,
maybe you have a couple of scrambled
a couple of eggs, you know,
but don't even start the
egg debate with people. Uh,
too much cholesterol than other
people. Well, if you scramble it,
you get rid of all the fuck nutrients
would you want to do is soft cook it?
I like good egg over easy, whatever.
I have a couple of fucking eggs.
Just don't have any toast,
bacon and potatoes.
Just throw those on the side of a gently.
That's a good fucking thing.
I don't know.
And then a lunch,
I just been doing the fucking Turkey
slices, little bit of Avocado.
I'll actually have a sandwich.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll have a couple of slices of bread
even though people say don't do that.
And then I after that,
it's just fucking a giant salad,
some sort of fucking
vegetarian thing for dinner.
And then all I got to do is take my dog
on a hike, do couple of pushups and uh,
not fucking booze and it's been going good
for me. So that's been working for me.
I hope it works for you. So anyways, um,
continuing on. So I've been,
uh, I've been flying here,
I'm trying to get my hours up.
My school recommended that I fly with an
instructor for different times just to
get radio calls down and I've done,
um,
I've done three flights
and this last flight I did,
I flew out to Catalina island,
which a lot of people don't know about
unless you live out here in La and you
probably know about it.
You never went to it. Um,
I didn't have the time to land cause I
had to go do some F is for family shit by
the way,
which is looking really funny by the way.
We got the first episode almost totally
edited and I was beyond excited,
um, up until that point I
was like, I don't know man.
I don't know how funny this is
going to be. You get all nervous.
And yesterday we just fucking
worked on the thing. Um,
I don't know from like two o'clock
to about nine o'clock at night,
just tightening it up and tighten it up,
tighten it up,
editing it and all that type of shit.
And uh,
I was able to keep my add under control.
I really do hit the wall at some
point where I'm like, I just,
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
But um,
they're really good about just
ignoring me when I say that.
It's like he became the running joke
cause I kept going. I have a hard out,
I have a hard out at seven,
I have to be Outta here by seven.
And then it was like seven 30 and
then it just became the running joke.
I just kept saying, I have a hard off
guys like guys, I'm not kidding around.
And they, and they would just be like,
oh yeah, but oh yeah, you're right here.
You're going to get you out of
here by seven. Um, so anyways, uh,
yesterday before he went over there,
I did a flight with one of my instructors
out to Catalina island. Like I said,
we didn't have time to land. It's a
just off the coast, about 23 miles,
24 of 25 miles off of, uh Oh
wait, is that how far it is?
No, I think they aren't back was
like 25 miles. I think that, yeah,
I think that's what it was.
Anyway.
So right off the coast of
Vile Long Beach and uh,
we flew out there and I saw my
first whale, if you can believe it,
we're flying out there.
We got the doors off,
which is actually great because if
he had to do an emergency landing,
that's kind of a bitch to have to fucking,
you know,
tried to open the Goddamn doors and
shit. I just like immediately, uh,
hitting the water and get the fuck out,
you know?
Um, so what, what is that
fucking procedure? I should
know that, right? Yeah.
I know what it is,
right?
You go into your flare and then when
you pull your power, but he's a skids.
Hit the water. You fucking
go. You go left cyclic, right.
You rolled down to the tent too, right?
You go left cyclic in the fucking blade.
Stop hopefully.
And then you just sit there
and hope somebody picks you
up before the sharks get
you. And that's what I was thinking when
I was flying over it going like, Bill,
you are fucking terrified
over the ocean right now.
And that was that halfway point that we
got to with the altitude that we were at
where it wasn't even that
we fly it like 2000 feet.
So basically once we got to a
certain point off the coast,
if we had a fucking problem, we'd
have to ditch it in the fucking ocean.
So you just hold onto a,
that's not going to happen to me.
So anyways,
we flew out there,
saw up two pods of dolphins and
at the altitude that we're at,
they like glow and they're
jumping out of the water.
It looked like look like a well
those little fireflies man,
it was fucking amazing. And then
um, the guy was a flying with,
you know, he was looking for whales cause
he knew I never saw him when he goes,
they haven't won it. There was one
that has one and know and he's like,
I have controls, you have
controls. I have control.
So he now he's flying and I was
looking and I got to watch the thing.
Come right up, take a breath, you know,
blow the fucking water out. Right.
Take a breath and then dive down again
man. It was fucking amazing. So, uh,
I'll actually, you know what, I'll, I'll
give you guys some pictures of that.
We had the um, you know,
life vests on and shit,
I'm not going to send you the
picture of me cause I'm slouched.
I look like a Douche in the, the,
the life jackets around your waist,
like a fucking fanny pack.
So I'm not going to show you that.
I'll just show you the view of,
uh, when we came in to Catalina,
it was fucking amazing. And then, uh,
went around the island
and flew back and uh,
just an incredible God damn flight.
So I'm really enjoying that.
But I'm getting to the point where all
freckles is going to be up there by
himself and I'm feeling pretty
confident about it. And, uh, who knows?
I might put a Gopro on one of these days
and I'll show you some of the shit when
I fly over dodger stadium when there's
no game and like that jerk off when we
were in the fucking, uh,
Hollywood bowl. All right,
let me get to the advertising
here for the week. Um, all right,
I got to do this right. Oh,
video, doorbell everybody.
I think it's only fair at
this point that uh, you know,
I did the music I gotta have, I gotta
have the fucking sad music underneath it,
right? Isn't that right? Here we go.
I just looked up 90 minutes of,
I looked up sad music on youtube and
this is 90 minutes of sad emotional music
you'll never forget.
Alright, so here we go.
Just the levels here.
Come on.
You fucking cut.
Hello everyone.
I'm Pilbara and I'd like to take a
couple minutes to talk to you about video
doorbell.
This is the side of a package
being delivered or friends
coming over for dinner,
but it's also the sound of
someone planning to rob you.
Blind tie you up and stick
there dangling in your mouth.
Yeah.
Over 95% of home breakings happened
during the day in burglars.
Almost always start by ringing your
doorbell to see if someone's home before
pillaging your possessions.
I can't fucking do this,
kip. Fucking this creeping me out.
What? Keep going. All right, you can't.
So I'll keep going
with ring video doorbell.
Yeah,
you can see and talk to anyone at your
door from anywhere in the world using
your smartphone each year,
over a thousand people suffer
from not having video doorbell.
Please help us get video
doorbells to the third world.
Most of these people
don't even have homes.
At least they could start with a video.
Doorbell rings.
Advanced motion detection alerts you,
even if someone doesn't ring the doorbell,
it's like a caller id for your home.
Please share a personal story.
I'm not sure fucking doing
that for the last fucking time.
Okay.
Why don't you guys at least send me a
fucking video door, but you know what?
I don't want one. I don't
want, you know what?
If somebody comes during the
day and fucking rob speak gain,
can you got me good on you?
You got me, you cunt. You know,
and I don't believe in Karma either.
I only believe in it if you,
if you believe in it. All right,
let's get back with the ring.
Video.
Doorbell
installing ring takes minutes and it
works with either your current wiring or
Builtin rechargeable battery.
Puts your mind at ease and protect your
home with video doorbell Time magazine
named it one of the top 10 gadgets
of 2014
trying to be a cunt,
but gadgets is probably the lowest award.
Yeah,
you don't even get inventions.
That's a gadget. Who'd you beat out?
Something that chops up an onion,
easily
put your mind at ease. Uh, right now
my listeners get ring video doorbell.
The only a hundred sits
is not sad video music.
This is some guy with a mullet
blown in the fucking wind right now.
My listeners get ring video
doorbell for only $174.
That's $25 off the normal price.
Go to ring.com/burn now protect your
home and have peace of mind with ring.
Go to ring.com/burn for $25 off.
It's ring.com/burr.
Thank you for listening.
God bless America.
That fade out was the shit that was done
half by me moving the microwave and the
other half, bringing the volume
down for all your texts out there.
I'll you techie heads out
there. Um, top tech gadgets.
That's an interesting gadget. It's not
smart enough to be an invention. Um,
me on days, everybody,
me, Andy's me undies,
no more sweaty testicles.
But who though? To me?
Undies me undies, slapping off
your fucking chest, the calls.
Um, that's the percent of your life that
you're in your underwear and underwear.
It gets old fast. You know that feeling
of putting on old saggy underwear? Oh,
you need to know the feeling
of great fitting underwear.
There's two times softer than
cotton, cotton, coffin, cotton.
You need to know about me, undies,
me undies poem on your fucking balls.
Oh yeah. Right. Smoothing
out your fucking Tate.
They even got him for the ladies.
Me undies has the most comfortable
underwear you will ever try on.
And it's insane how good they
make you feel. They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you
and they literally pull
moisture rows away from your
skin. See a stay cool man. But they
also look, make you look great.
So go to [inaudible] dot com and check
out the photography and for the late
check out those smoking hot boy shorts.
But you have to try them on for yourself
so you can have no more sweaty clam
even if fees finger in. Yeah. Um,
this quality would typically retail for
two times the me Andy Price. I mean,
I guess you'd have to be up on fucking
underwear to know if that's actually a
claim that can be backed up.
No retail middleman means more savings
for you here. We will make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burn
and get 20% off your first order and low
flat rate.
International shipping save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy
with them or your first pair is free.
Once you feel me undies on your body,
you're never going back.
You can be walking around with half Ohad
on there and me undies isn't just for
guys.
They just launched their all at me.
Why not take all of me but do,
but they,
we will Robin against that
fucking beautiful clam pow.
Your clam is dry unless you're
thinking about some Dick.
Oh, maybe you're a lesbian. Thinking
about Twat, we really made it, um,
that guarantee you that your
claim is going to remain dry.
A four piece line of undies designed
specifically for the female body and all
its compact, complex,
gorgeous, has held glory.
Why can't you say that about a fucking
unit? Huh? This is reversed sexism.
But to get 20% off,
you have to go to [inaudible] dot com
slash bird that's Emmy undies.com/burr.
All right? And last but
not least, zip recruiter.
Are you hiring? But not sure
where to find the best candidates?
Are you sitting on a couch? But not sure
it's there. Are you on drugs right now?
Uh,
as a business owner,
I can tell you that your company is only
as good as the people you hire. Well,
you don't need to tell us that that's ob
really is the team only as good as the
players your draft.
What if I have a great game
plan and everybody's socks?
Do we still win? Um, can I,
I can also tell you that posting your
job in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates,
especially if you put that thing up down
at the bus station because God knows
what's reading it. Uh, but when
you, when you're short staffed,
there's no time to deal with dozens
of different job sites until now,
thanks to zip recruiter.com.
Evidently I can post to 100 plus
job sites with a single click.
I'm not even hiring anybody and I could
do that just post once within 24 hours.
Watch your candidates
roll in to Ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use interface plus be instantly
matched to candidates from over 4
million resumes
ZipRecruiter has just used,
has been used by over 400,000 businesses
and you can try it right now for
absolutely fucking free.
Get the right people for your company.
Getting the right people for
your company is so important.
Try ZipRecruiter and get
your perfect candidate before
they go to somewhere else.
Someone else today.
You can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr
that's ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible]
I want to Jim Mercy uses that, Huh?
Uh, no, he just tanks and
entire fucking season out bill.
When you trim your counties. All right,
Uber, everyone. This is the last one.
Mercifully intro. Hey, you like
making great money, right? Sure.
We all do.
Here's a really cool opportunity that
I just had to share with you evidently
driving with Uber.
Uber is that popular smartphone APP
that connects riders with drivers.
I take Uber a bunch. No I
don't. I take taxis. Okay.
I'd take taxis cause
they don't know who I am.
And I'm not trying to be an arrogant ass.
I just appealed to people who drive Uber.
You know what I mean?
If I take a bus that he doesn't know
who the fuck I am, I take the subway,
Hey I know what the fuck I am. I go and
play and they don't know the fuck I am.
Something about Uber, something about
singing, no more sweaty, clammy.
We really meet that just connects with
these cons but you know, whatever. Um,
everyday I love them by the way. And
in chatting with the different drivers,
some of them have really interesting
stories as to why they drive with Uber.
They love being their own boss. They
earn great money. It's easy to start.
You just need a car and a license.
Driving with Uber is great for anyone
who needs flexibility. Parents,
this is really easy way to work
under your family's schedule.
They were like 20 of
these points. Stone, it's,
you can make extra money between classes.
No more stripping layer.
I just go topless. I feel it's
more like an artistic thing. Um,
now that now's the prime
time to cash in with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling
you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your car
when you drive over a call to action,
you got a car and a driver's license,
right? We'll put 'em together.
Stupid to work for you and start
serious life changing money today.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com.
That's drive with e u B e r.com.
That's drive with uber.com. Uh,
you should definitely do this,
man.
This is a great way to supplement
your fucking income. But what it is,
when you have that extra
income, don't fucking drink
it away. Put it up, you know,
is a buy some shoes. Pay Down your
fucking dead and become a free man.
Pay Down your credit cards. Pay Down your
student loans. Get out of fucking debt.
Don't owe anybody any money. All
right? You don't owe anybody anything.
They owe you. You want to stand it.
That's still what you want to stand it.
You want to stand that. That's the
way to go. I'd love to keep talking,
but my internet sucks here and that's
going to take forever for me to fucking
upload this thing. Um, anyways, that
was me just checking in on you. Hey,
it's Friday everybody fucking Friday.
It's the fucking east coast at this point.
What is it? 11 a two
o'clock. You're almost there.
You're almost there.
Whatever. Um, anyways, uh,
thanks to everybody who's been listening.
Uh,
yeah.
Why don't I feel like I've got
to thank everybody this week.
I just had a fucking awesome week.
I did. I had a fucking great week.
I'm just psyched. I'm losing weight.
I'm turning this ship around.
You know what's funny too is fucking
how much your skin clears up. You know,
and I don't need you guys
with your fucking horse shit
when you're just going to
go look up stuff about your Liverpool's
because of the toxins your liver is able
to get rid of. I understand that. I
can also Google what the fuck happens,
although nobody will
give me an actual number.
Why can it get an extra we'll number?
Does anybody know? What is the,
I mean it obviously depends
on how much you boost.
And I booze pretty hard, but when an
ice stopped boozing, I just miss boots.
Like I didn't fucking get the sweats,
you know what I mean?
I didn't fucking get the shakes,
you know,
they didn't have to lock me in a room
with fucking chicken broth or any of that
type of shit. I just miss it. You
know what I mean? There I said it,
I miss it like a friend. Um, all
right. That's it. I'm going to send,
I'm going to upload some
pictures of a flying around
Catalina and I'll, oh, so, uh,
I'll,
I'll upload that thing of Keith Carlock
killing it a while he's playing Asian.
I'm telling you guys, even if you're
not, even if you don't play drums,
you just gotta see, you gotta see
this fucking band, their horn section,
that bass player, fucking everybody
destroyed it. And um, you got to go see.
All right. That's it. That's
the, that's the podcast.
And I'm going to get a
little throwback here.
Half hour above podcast
from days gone past.
And it's only a month out from fucking
football season, right? There'll be,
they'll be playing three seasons.
Think about that.
All right or don't think about it.
Oh,
let's go get something to
eat. I said, all right,
here's a fucking Mcdonald's
right there and she's like,
do you want to eat there? And started
was looking down at the ground, all sad,
you know,
just doing that classic
female manipulation thing.
She knew I wanted to eat there.
I just said there's a Mcdonald's
there and then why would she say,
do you want to eat there
and look down at the ground?
This question is for all the young male
listeners, if my whispering podcast,
why would a female do
that? Do, do, do, do,
do. I'll tell you why.
Because she doesn't want,
if not only does she not
want to fucking eat there,
she already has a place where
she wants to eat. She's our,
she's already had this
place that she's wanting,
wanting to eat at for probably a
month before you ever went to Vegas.
But she's not going to tell you about it
because if she tells you about it that
give you time to do research on it and
find out how fucking expensive it was.
Yeah.
So should I take you out to eat and she
looks down at the ground. So immediately,
despite the fact that I know all this
about females, I take the bait. Why?
Where do you want to eat sweetheart?
Um,
there's this burger place at Mandalay bay.
I heard it was really nice.
Do you ever watch top chef? Uh, only
when you're watching it sweetheart.
I don't like that show.
Fucking show is annoying.
I hate when the shift starts screaming
at those people. Fucking foreign accent.
He called that a fucking grilled cheese
sandwich. Get the fucker in my kitchen.
Hey. Hey, you think I'm fucking
afraid of you? You fucking dope.
You got a fucking problem with
my grilled cheese sandwich.
You come up like a fucking
gentleman and you take me aside.
Don't fucking be screaming at me. Well,
I got these fucking knives in my hand.
Stick it right to your God damn
trachea. What you think about that? Huh?
I'll give you a fucking blow holes right
out the front of your fucking neck.
Get out of my goddamn face before I take
your value fucking hair and wash your
face into this pile of shrimp.
Huh?
That I haven't taken the shells off so
I'll give you a bunch of little razor
cuts. Sorry. That's a good
shit. At Mandalay Bay.
The bad shit is we go to
this fucking burger place.
I can't remember the name of it.
We go in there and I,
I order a $16 and 50 cent fucking Coby
beef burger and they're talking about how
it's the greatest God
Damn Burger. I'll, I'll,
you know the highest quality
fucking meat, Yadda, fucking Yada.
My girl orders one to 1615
1650 what is that kid?
That's 33 bucks plus fries plus drinks,
all that bullshit. You know the
mob doesn't run Vegas anymore.
You can't go out and
get yourself a $2 stake.
The whole fucking place out there
now is a god damn. It's a fuck over.
So whatever cost me like 40 something
bucks, 50 bucks with the goddamn tip,
I eat it. A aunt wasn't even that
good. My girls like, how's your burger?
You know what I said? I said,
it's good just keeping the peace,
keeping the water nice and smooth.
Nice and fucking still on the horizon.
Okay.
So anyways,
I get back to my hotel.
My girl already tells me she doesn't feel
too good at that burger sitting in or
like a God damn boot. And I'm
like, you know what? I feel fine.
I get ready to do my show.
I end my button down shirt,
put a little conditioner in my hair,
what's left of it,
shape it up a little and I head
downstairs to go work the Orleans casino.
The last place Carlin ever worked, the
place where the smothers brothers retired,
you know,
smothers brothers who was so fucking edgy.
They actually lost their sketch show
during the Vietnam War. They did.
So I forget what the sketch was,
but they had the balls to
say no to the network and do
a sketch that was actually criticizing
what the fuck we were doing over there
and they lost it. God Damn Show, you
know, I don't know about you guys,
but for me, that's lifetime
for respect. So anyways,
I walked down there and I'm going through
the Orleans casino and then all of a
sudden it just fucking hits me. Boom.
Right. My stomach, like some capsule,
some time release.
CIA,
you're going to shit your
pants fucking capsule goes off.
And I know there is no question that
whatever I just ate was not good for my
body.
And it was about to reject it one way or
the other without getting crude people,
when something goes into your stomach,
if it's coming out,
it only has two options.
All right.
Anyways,
I just thought of a really,
really bad joke for the fucking third
one and I'm not going to say it,
but it involved stabbing yourself in the
stomach and you can fill in the blanks
on that one. All right. So anyways, um,
tell him he gotta be fucking, do you
gotta be shitting me? No Pun intended.
So I go in the back way,
the same way that Carlin used to go in,
cause I've already asked everybody every
fucking question. Literally so much.
I'm into Carlin. How did he
leave? Did he hang out now?
He'd say good night and he would go
right out the door and he'd be in the car
and he wasn't difficult to work with.
I guess he had arthritis at
the end of his life. And uh,
the sound guy was saying one show you
forgot to take the bottle caps off the
water bottles and he saw the car loan
was struggling with them and when he got
off because George, I'm so sorry. I'm so
sorry. And George just like whack al come.
I'd come out and I don't give a
shit. Don't worry. Just walked out.
I guess he was a really great guy.
So anyways,
I'm walking through this legendary door
and uh,
you know, and what's worse is like,
I know what's going to happen,
but I know it's not going to
happen for like another 15 minutes.
And coincidentally the fucking show starts
in 15 minutes and I'm going on first.
All right? And this guy,
when you're backstage,
literally says 20 minutes till showtime,
20 minutes till showtime,
he liked counts it down.
I ain't never get nervous before shows,
but this guy counting down
the show is making me nervous.
15 minutes till showtime, okay. And
it's starting to get worse and fuck it.
Get literally gets down to two minutes
before showtime. And I'm questioning,
can I make it through a half hour
set? And I was like, you know what?
Fuck this.
The show can't start without me.
My opening music is Elvis Presley.
Anyways, the fuck do I care?
They can listen to that song.
Oh, going robe of illegals.
Lose your long block her,
Slam your fork and fully solve
the fucking sink. A Ho, Ho,
I don't give a shit. And I said, fuck it.
And I fucking ran into the bathroom.
And I will spare you the details.
But you know,
when something either amazing
or,
uh, something amazing
happens, they make a statue.
If something horrific happens, a lot
of times they will preserve the area.
You know, like Dealey Plaza. Fuck a
president gets his brains blown out.
All of a sudden we can't change one blade,
a fucking grass.
The horror that happened in that
fucking bathroom, ladies and gentlemen,
I never do shit jokes. They should
have retired that fucking bathroom.
That's it. They should
have just fucking, uh,
air sealed it and just
put a glass fucking door.
Two people could look in and realize why
they closed that fucking burger joint
at the Mandalay Bay and a, I got
to met, dude. I have, I haven't,
this is Monday.
I'm finally back to normal.
So there you go.
There's my big shit story.
I had a burger over at the
fucking Mandalay bay and
it almost ruined my fucking
show over at the Orleans. So if you guys
saw me, anybody saw me Saturday night.
All right,
you want to talk about a professional
because I extra fucking killed on that
show.
If you knew what the fuck happened,
just know that the next time you go to
Vegas and you go to see Barry Manilow and
he's singing that song,
Mandy,
you something and you saw
amped and then you stomped and,
but I still want to fuck
you. Oh, Mandy. Right.
Just know that he could have just been
shit in his fucking brains out two
minutes before he put on his ray on
fucking slacks with his horrific plastic
surgery is yank back face.
I bet you know.
I was going to say he did another
facelift if he fucking shit the way I did
before my show. But that's actually
not true. There's no strain.
There was no straining. Um, anyways.
All right bill. Jesus Christ.
Enough already.
All right, here we go. Here's a
question for a week. Uh, Bill,
let me start by saying this.
This question stems from events
spanning over the last six years or so.
About six years ago,
at the age of 20,
I was about a year and a half into what
at the time seemed to be a really great
relationship.
Coincidentally,
my job and money situation
was also doing really well.
Um,
so I decided instead of throwing my
money away on rent, I'd buy a house.
There you go. This guy's making the moves.
He's doing well in life, buying a house.
Everything's good.
So far being that I always plan ahead.
I purchased a rather nice
house for a first home,
even though I thought, uh, he said,
even thought I knew it, even though I
knew it was a little too much money. Um,
now I didn't decide I didn't buy
this to start a family or for her.
I just wanted a fucking house,
uh,
in the year or so after the
relationship really went downhill,
mainly because I was working more in
spending less time and money on her.
Um, okay. Uh, long story short,
we split about two years later. Since
then, I've had many encounters with girls.
Okay. So let me, let me fix this
with my awful reading. All right.
Basically, this guy's dating a
girl. He's making good money,
doesn't want to throw his money
down the toilet, paying rent.
So he goes and he buys in house.
And then now he's got a nut to fucking
crack every month he works a little bit
more. He's not spending time with his
woman and it downhill plus these younger.
That's pretty normal except
the fact that he owns a house.
So now he's in this situation,
he's single,
he has this really nice house and this is
what's been happening since. All right.
Since then,
I've had many encounters with girls.
The one thing they have all had in common
is their hatred and animosity towards
my ex girlfriend and my house.
I've even heard them say things about
sleeping in a bed I bought with her or how
they don't like it that I did all
this with, uh, with the other girl.
I've been dating a girl for about two
years now and she's the same way. Uh,
she even has problems with my dogs
because she says they were her dogs,
meaning the ex. My question is this,
why is it never good enough? Well,
if you're a fan of this podcast,
you've already asked that question,
but I think it's timeless. So I'm going
to go, that's why I'm reading this again.
Am I suppose to start my life over every
time I want to begin a new relationship
or is it that girls really always
want to have what they can.
They cannot have half the country nowadays
are just waiting for some guy to put
them up in a house and
take care of everything.
But when you give them the chance,
they bitch because they didn't
get to pick the fucking drapes.
Yeah.
Oh, this guy is making some good points
near, I'm going to need your help. Paris.
Uh, I don't, uh, I don't get it.
I've done really well for myself
and I've done it on my own.
None of that had anything to do
with who I was dating at the time.
And I hate feeling bad
because I'm trying to make,
because I'm trying to better myself.
What should take all right.
Nia, what did you say on this? She summed
it up really well here. What do you,
what do you think about this guy? Just
to, just to reiterate, you know, the deal.
What, what, what is,
uh, what is his problem?
I think the problem is the
kind of people that he dates,
cause I don't think that
they're mature enough.
So like let go of the past, you
know what I mean? It's like,
of course he stayed at other women, of
course. You know what I mean? It's not,
yeah, but let me ask you this. If, if
when I met you already had a house, right.
And uh, it was, you know, it had a
little bit of the female touch to it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. You know what I mean?
It's not like you walked in and there was
just a coffee table and like fucking a
play station, you know, popcorn in
the cushions or whatever. Right.
I'm not saying this house looks like
that, but you know. Right. Yeah. No, they,
it looked like, and I still had the bed
that I used to bang the other one me.
Then I'll say, at least she can do,
dude, you can leave, switch out the bed.
You know what I mean?
Led though I thought. I think that's a
little, I think that's a little much,
honestly. What did the little much to
still have it? Yeah. He's going to buy it.
Do you have much better because you
don't have him buy a whole new bed just
cause he's slept with somebody else on it.
Ladies,
can you see why this is my
girl? You're the shit. Yeah,
because I mean how many,
when you're dating somebody and you
have sex with them in their house,
chances are they've had sex with somebody
else in their bed before you anyway.
So now all of a sudden it's
like a big deal because no, he,
he needs to date some more mature girls,
but he's been dating someone
for two years. Uh, I don't
know what he's been doing.
I thought you said he, I just
focused on saying the words, right?
Yeah. He says, you know
what? You know what this,
this house could be like
the lock to the lock,
the door tests in them in a Bronx
tale. Oh yeah, that's true. Yeah.
Like if if they can't deal with
and they start giving me shit,
you give them the heave Ho.
Exactly.
I think they should get the
heave Ho this is my house.
This is where I fuck you want in.
Well not quite so asshole,
but if anything he could,
you know, get some new
sheets or something. You
know what? I know obviously.
Oh yeah. Bed, bath and beyond. I'm
thinking about some new sheets.
You want to help me pick out some
girl would love that. Love it. Yeah.
There you go. Yeah, there you go. Yeah.
At what point in the relationship
should he do that? You know,
cause we don't like being tied down.
I want to send the wrong message.
I don't want to say that I love you,
but I want you to still bang me.
Like at what point?
I think when it's like official date,
like a monogamous type thing is when
you can say, hey, lets you know.
Okay. All right. That's really, you
answered the question, don't oversell it.
You answered it. I think it's really
annoying that these girls would be like,
oh my God, I can't believe that, you know,
this is already decorated and these
are her dogs and as her house,
and I can tell that she's
saying that's stupid.
That's how I say how la girls
say favorite. That's my favorite.
All right.
All right. I think that's going
to be the podcast for this week.
So I guess so that's your answer
right there. And you know,
I'm not going to always defer those, uh,
to Nia, but I just think sometimes you're,
you're really asking me what women are
thinking and I think I've done enough
trashing of women and, uh, shut up.
MMM.
I'm done enough trashing of them.
And you know,
that's actually a serious question
here because still, you know,
you don't want to get that in a situation
where, I mean, you have to, I mean,
literally sell the house. What if it's a
bad fucking market just to appease her?
That's ridiculous.